[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie
aujourd'hui j'ai la grande joie de
recevoir un yvelinois qui s'appelle Eric
Janssen il est auteur journaliste
photographe
Eric Janssen bonjour Véronique merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
d'être venu de si loin pour nous
rejoindre voilà vous êtes l'auteur d'un
livre co-auteur pardon oui vous avez
raison d'un livre qui vient de sortir
chez Gourcuff ça s'appelle très cher
baronne de Rothschild le voici le voilà
que vous avez co-écrit avec qui et bien
avec Nadine de Rothschild c'est
absolument voilà ça c'est dit donc on va
en parler tout à l'heure moi déjà
j'aimerais en connaître un petit peu
plus sur vous
quel est votre domaine de prédilection
Nadine en fait on va tout de suite en
parler j'ai été son attaché de presse
j'étais très jeune attaché de presse et
justement en essayant de contacter les
journalistes quand on fait pour les
quand on est attaché de presse je
poursuivais point de vue
pour avoir un article et donc je suis
entré assez rapidement à point de vue je
suis devenu journaliste à point de vue
et j'ai gardé de très bons contacts avec
Nadine je parle de ça il y a 30 ans et
donc et donc pendant 30 ans c'est 30 ans
d'amitié ce livre ah c'est donc voilà
donc journaliste à point de vue et puis
donc pas les rois les reines plutôt
toute l'autre partie du magazine donc
les les demeures les jardins les
collectionneurs les couturiers les voilà
donc ça c'est sympa le marché de l'art
exactement donc ça a été ça pendant
toujours d'ailleurs et vous êtes
journaliste photographe
voilà et ensuite ça c'était que point de
vue et puis depuis une dizaine d'années
je fais aussi les photos et donc ce qui
permet d'avoir un sujet clé en main
texte et photo et donc je travaille
maintenant indépendamment pour plusieurs
supports pour plusieurs magazines qui
sont par exemple les échos beaucoup pour
les échos et donc c'est toujours
lifestyle donc c'est toujours des
histoires de collectionneurs des très
jolies maisons des jardins des voilà
toujours le même niveau oui et puis on
retombe très vite voilà le livre
justement au fil des portraits des
baronnes qu'elle évoque ce ne sont
qu'une succession de maison qu'une
succession de collection de tableaux de
mobiliers donc en arrière pardon vous
avez reçu le prix du Trianon Palace il y
a quelques années
sur les cabinets de curiosité
ce livre est né grâce justement à une
sélection de ce reportages que j'avais
pu faire chez des chez des
collectionneurs
l'idée c'était l'éclectisme ce que les
nouveaux cabinets d'amateurs c'était
l'éclectisme et surtout la
rajouter c'est qu'on savait chez qui on
était généralement vous avez des livres
de décoration totalement anonymes alors
que là les les 24 25 qui avait accepté
d'ouvrir leur porte c'était aussi leur
portraits
de l'objet s'amusant mais c'est souvent
évidemment le collectionneur et c'est
très intime on se réveille et donc voilà
alors voilà donc cette amitié avec la
baronne Nadine de Rothschild se Noé donc
comme on a dit vous avez été son attaché
de presse mais est-ce que vous avez
commis d'autres livres ensemble d'autres
livres assez rapidement en fait parce
que déjà elle est évidemment très
attachante donc moi ça m'amusait de de
et puis elle est très enthousiaste elle
est toujours hein elle est partante donc
dès qu'il y en a une idée amusante dès
qu'il y a quelques voilà une chose qui
peut la à partir de l'ordinaire et voilà
donc on a fait deux trois livres
ensemble
le plus amusant je crois je sais pas si
on le trouve encore c'était sur les
chemins de l'amour où nous sommes partis
sur les lieux où c'était déroulés les
plus grandes histoires d'amour donc on
est allé à Vérone sur les traces de
Roméo et Juliette à dans le monde aux
États mal faire une photo juste pour une
photo devant le tâche mal
juste après
c'est le Taj mal c'était une photo qu'on
a faite pour pour sur les chemins de
l'amour on racontait l'histoire du
tajmal et dehors et donc on est allé à
Stromboli pour Rossellini en italien
alors c'est pas tout à fait c'est dire
que l'éditeur à l'époque avait encore un
peu de un peu de moyens donc c'était
l'éditeur qui avait financé on dirait je
sais pas un tiers
photos très amusants
et toutes les photos je les avais faites
donc il le portrait de la couverture
c'est un de mes portraits d'ailleurs le
portrait on l'a fait en septembre
dernier et elle a on peut le dire parce
que elle est née en 32 donc là elle a 90
ans et on l'avait le portrait était chez
elle en Suisse c'est pour ça qu'elle
n'est pas là ce aujourd'hui
non non en fait elle est dans une dans
une maison dans la campagne le château
elle
y va encore mais elle est vraiment dans
la campagne au milieu des vignes 20
minutes une demi-heure du château de
prago et alors qu'est-ce qui lui donne
justement encore envie d'écrire à 90 ans
mais ça chacun il y a un enthousiasme il
y a un enthousiasme
sur les chemins de l'amour on évoquait
les grandes figures comme ça un peu les
histoires d'amour mythique nous fait
deux autres livres c'était les hommes de
ma vie
à chaque fois elle aime elle a beaucoup
d'humour donc évidemment les hommes de
ma vie on trouvait que c'était un titre
assez saine tout de suite accrocheur et
amusant et donc hop à cette occasion là
elle évoque ses souvenirs et elle évoque
elle a une très très bonne mémoire
vraiment et parce que je contrôle quand
même tout
journaliste donc ce contrôle les dates
je contrôle les et vraiment à chaque
fois il y a peut-être une peut-être une
petite erreur de date sur un film ou
parce qu'elle a tourné une trentaine de
films quand même on a complètement
oublié le côté carrière il y a eu 10 ans
10 ans de de cinéma avant de se marier
ça c'était ça voilà absolument ça il a
beaucoup compté mais donc voilà donc en
fait il y a la mémoire donc c'est
passionnant parce que et puis c'est une
époque parce que justement dans le livre
qui est donc le principe du livre on va
l'expliquer c'est que elle a voulu enfin
vous avez voulu
tracer le le portrait de toutes les
Baronnies de Rothschild de la famille
voilà alors pas toutes
on a une sélection en fait ce qui au fil
de ses souvenirs donc il y a eu les
hommes de ma vie il y a eu les l'amour
est à faire de femmes où elle faisait la
même chose c'est-à-dire les grands
portraits de toutes les femmes qu'elle
avait pu croiser durant durant sa vie
donc elle parle de Diana parce qu'elle
l'a croisé d'Elizabeth II parce que la
croisée bon et donc à chaque fois et
puis de Jackie Kennedy par exemple pour
voilà donc ça c'est très amusant mais
alors il y avait toujours une allusion
enfin il y a toujours une phrase sur sa
belle-mère Noémie sur le le la baronne
Julie parce que le château de Pregny
c'était la baronne Julie donc julie
était très ami avec ici et impératrice
donc on parlait de Sicile voilà mais
c'était toujours comme ça un paragraphe
ou deux et un jour je lui dis mais ça
serait très amusant quand même de de
creuser ça de tirer le fil parce que
Julie la seule coup en creusant on
s'aperçoit que que un personnage
extraordinaire complètement excentrique
c'est donc ça c'est ce qu'on appelait
viennent de la branche de Naples et il
s'installe après nous Naples on ferme la
succursale on quitte Naples c'est une
des branches qui n'a pas marché entre
guillemets les fameux cinq branches des
Rothschild il s'installe après nid et
elle donc évidemment avec des moyens
très importants le mari se consacre à sa
collection de d'oeuvre d'art et de
mobilier donc c'est une collection
époustouflée en 18e même éclectique là
pour le coup ça marcherait très bien
dans le cabinet d'amateurs très
éclectique des choses médiévales aussi
des choses religieuses et elle elle a
une passion c'est de faire les courses
de bateaux sur le lac donc elle se fait
construire elle se fait construire des
des des bateaux de course à vapeur et
elle a fait la course ça devait être une
des seules femmes à faire ça c'est je
pense que c'est la en tout cas une des
premières oui d'accord
elle d'un seul coup on creuse et c'est
passionnant et c'est très amusant et ça
permet de raconter aussi un peu le
Naples et puis ça permet de raconter ses
amitiés donc Elisabeth l'histoire qui
évidemment chante Nadine enfin c'est une
histoire triste mais si si se fait
poignarder le lendemain d'avoir pris le
thé avec la baronne Julie après midi
donc en fait il y a toujours la
garnisseur la petite histoire comme ça
et puis si on si on commence avec Julie
bah on tire le fil donc au même moment
la même époque à peu près bah il y a
Betty à Paris donc James ça c'est le la
branche française donc la plus
prestigieuse Betty voilà donc d'un seul
coup alors eux ils sont vraiment il y a
encore des maisons il y a encore donc on
retrouve énormément de documentations et
puis et puis
plus connu je pense du grand public
c'est Béatrice et frucide Rothschild
puisque c'est la Villa La Villa
efrussier de Rothschild donc ça c'est
ouvert au public depuis très à
Saint-Jean-Cap-Ferrat donc donc la
grande sur la Côte d'Azur très jolie
villa musée depuis très très longtemps
et donc et ensuite on s'est intéressé
parce que je me suis dit bon on a quatre
cinq amusantes parce qu'elles sont
toutes
et Russie elle a un parcours
complètement donc ça c'est Noemi donc ça
c'est la belle-mère ça c'est la
belle-mère de Nadine voilà absolument et
donc la mère des noms qui a créé la
station Megève donc elle elle l'a
vraiment créé toutes pièces c'était un
petit village elle a acheté des des
centaines d'hectares elle a créé le
Domaine du Mont d'Arbois et les
remontées mécaniques etc donc elle est
vraiment à l'origine de la station de
ski voilà et elle elle elle est décédée
âgée et donc nadine a très bien connu il
a très bien connu sa belle-mère et qui
était qui était vaincu comme elles sont
toutes elles étaient aussi dures
oui mais attachante
ravissante manière de faire le premier
déjeuner le test déjeuner elle avait vu
de loin lors d'un premier bal et qui est
organisé justement pour présenter Nadine
à la société ou tout Paris et ensuite il
y a eu déjeuner avec la belle-mère et
alors avec cette mais la belle-mère
après aurait dit très très joli maniaque
mais il faut pas oublier une chose c'est
que Nadine est emmené en 32 lorsqu'elle
épousée de mon en 63 elle a 31 ans elle
a pas 18 ans donc elle a une vie avant
elle a eu des donc elle est pas elle
n'est pas débutante du tout c'est pas le
bal des débutants
12 ans de de
vie dans le monde parce que
en étant petite comédienne puis un peu
starlette parce que quand elle va à
Cannes elle va elle monte les marches de
Cannes en 58 avec girl ADSI et enfin bon
c'est pas rester dans l'histoire du du
cinéma mais c'était très charmant et là
elle a une idylle avec un héritier
anglais le fils de Lady docker et donc
elle aurait pu être
après l'histoire ne s'est pas
concrétiser enfin en tout cas elle est
partie mais elle avait déjà voilà elle
était déjà dans une société élégante
du ruisseau mais quand même c'est moi
c'est ça qui m'a étonné c'est qu'elle
est écrit un livre sur les le
savoir-vivre les manières les
bienséances etc mais où d'où est-ce
qu'elle les a apprises alors parce que
en observant et en autant tout elle a je
les ai vus
elle a des cahiers mais des cahiers
depuis toujours il écrit tout mais tout
donc c'est comme ça
dans la nuit elle a écrit elle a eu une
idée donc elle elle écrit tout et donc
mais les maîtresses de maison des années
on va dire 5 ans de l'après-guerre
faisait ça on retrouve les cahiers
d'accord
c'était la même chose si la comtesse de
RIP c'était la même chose alors c'était
plus autour des dîners ou des ou des
voilà de de l'art de recevoir mais non
elle a cette mémoire là et puis
et puis je pense qu'en fait le métier de
comédienne pendant 10 ans la lui a donné
une pas un appel on serait trop dire oui
une aisance une aisance arbondir une
aisance elle raconte elle raconte
l'anecdote où elle est à Ferrière et
donc toutes les dames évidemment château
de Château de Ferrière donc on est chez
Guy et Marylène de Rothschild et au
château de Ferrières comme elle ils
avaient le Château d'hermainvilliers Les
américaine était consacré enfin il y
avait des weekends de chasse pas tous
les week-ends
elle se souvient d'un impair elle est
chez la reine Juliana des Pays-Bas en
week-end de chasse et et
ils viennent d'arriver elle s'installe
dans sa chambre une petite dame frappe à
la porte
est-ce que tout va bien oui oui mais
peut-être si vous pouviez me repasser
donner un coup de fer à ma robe pour le
dîner ce soir évidemment la petite dame
c'est la reine Juliana voilà c'était pas
la gouvernante c'était pas la femme de
chambre mais elle me dit mais je vais
pas reconnu parce que j'ai toujours que
j'avais vu une fois deux fois que la
couronne est là elle était avec une
petite robe toute simple c'est dire
qu'elle était mais voilà la reine
Juliana justement avec la tête de rire
et alors qu'est-ce qu'elle pense
aujourd'hui de de ces bonnes manières
qui ne sont plus tellement
usités est-ce qu'elle est désespérée
est-ce qu'elle est en mer très
régulièrement elle a des demandes c'est
impressionnant
et elle a eu un mot elle a déjà abdiqué
de démission de télévision de de
d'éditeur qui voudraient dire mais
comment comment se débrouiller
aujourd'hui au 21e siècle mais en fait
je suis sur les bonnes manières d'antan
à la vie actuelle mais ce serait basé
sur le bon sens et le respect des autres
tout simplement le livre le manuel du
savoir-vivre est sorti là les dates je
pense qu'il y a du sang
incroyable
même en chinois
il faudrait le rafraîchir mais en fait
l'époque oui mais l'époque a tellement
c'est tellement accéléré en 20 ans parce
que je pense qui date je dirais 94 enfin
les années 90 comme ça donc 30 ans donc
ça veut dire que aujourd'hui c'est même
plus une règle de évidemment pose pas
son téléphone sur la table pendant si on
déjeune ou on dîne avec quelqu'un bon
voilà mais ça c'est le c'est vraiment le
tout petit mais il y a mille choses la
rédaction de la correspondance enfin
donc c'est pour ça on y a pensé on y a
pensé l'adapter je lui avais dit il faut
le faire maintenant au 21e siècle on
avait commencé et en fait c'est pour ça
[Musique]
de la salle consacrée à la Dacia des
nombres chill au Louvre voilà on doit
être en 91 et bah il a attendu pendant
une heure et puis au bout d'une heure
elle a la considéré que
c'était bien qu'elle avait fait voilà et
donc elle est partie elle a croisé
effectivement
le mystes de Culture Jack Lang dans le
dans le couloir en disant j'arrive
j'arrive la salle est à vous
voilà donc elle se laisse pas marcher
sur les pieds et alors moi ce que je
trouve aussi intéressant c'est qu'on
retrouve dans toutes ces baronnes c'est
qu'en fait ce sont des c'est des petites
entreprises avec leur mari elle elles
sont ça rigole pas quand même assez
toutes ces réflexions
c'est vraiment les banquiers ils ont
besoin de clients ils ont besoin
d'appuyer politique et elle elles font
le relationnel c'est leur travail c'est
un vrai travail c'est pas uniquement
c'est pas toujours rigolo de d'aller
prendre le thé avec la barre
certaines ne bougent pas beaucoup nos
voyages pas beaucoup donc bon il y a
effectivement les week-ends de chasse il
y avait tout ça c'est au passé donc il y
avait les weekends de chasse il fallait
organiser ça il fallait organiser
évidemment les réceptions dans l'hôtel
particulier à Paris mais en gros ça se
limitait à ça mais avec Nadine et non
lui il a beaucoup beaucoup voyagé donc
donc
après ça c'était pour la banque vraiment
pour la banque elle le suivait partout
et donc mais aux États-Unis beaucoup et
puis surtout Edmond comme son grand-père
Edmond le vieil en dit le vieux baron
Edmond qui était vraiment à l'origine en
tout cas un des premiers à s'investir et
énormément
en Israël elle a repris ça elle a
vraiment fait elle s'est converti mais
alors pour le pour le mariage et après à
fond vraiment donc le je l'accompagnais
d'ailleurs elle y allait deux fois par
an à un moment vraiment parce qu'il y
avait énormément d'établissements
d'hôpitaux de choses qui se créent il y
a eu énormément de l'associations et de
choses voilà donc il y avait Israël en
plus il y avait le métier de la banque
Israël et puis c'est rajouté aussi ça ça
aussi beaucoup compté le vin parce que
avec château Clark elle a représenté le
vin partout dans le monde aussi et
plein d'anecdotes comme ça où on allait
dans des restaurants et elle prenait la
carte elle disait mais je ne vois pas
château Clark alors évidemment et donc
évidemment ça faisait un petit effet et
il commandait du château Clark à la
prochaine fois mais c'est passionnant
parce que elles ont toutes des vies
incroyables il y en a une qui qui
s'occupe de qui est biologiste en fait
elle était très sérieuse mais sérieuse
bien sûr
celle qui s'occupaient de la vie des
puces qui étudie la vie des puces alors
c'est drôle parce que la preuve alors
moi je connaissais l'histoire mais trois
lignes en disant il y avait cette on
avait aussi fait quelques baronnes
anglaises et donc cette baronne anglaise
ah oui elle a pas consacrer sa vie à
l'étude des puces
non non mais c'était très sérieux
son père avait fait la même chose son
oncle faisait la même chose et donc en
1880-1920 comme ça c'est ils étudient ça
avec beaucoup d'attention parce que ça
transmet les maladies parce que
c'est pas une fantaisie et une dernière
et après ça je vous libérer
je crois que c'est la baronne qui est
pour Marie-Antoinette
en 55 Gérald and vient de le château de
Versailles la Renaissance on peut dire
après guerre c'est Gérard landercut très
très
professionnel dans la mondanité donc
c'était pas juste comme ça c'était à
chaque fois séduire des mécènes séduire
des des grandes fortunes pour avoir des
pour vraiment restaurer Versailles et
donc il y a eu énormément de de dons
notamment de la famille
rothschilda mais pas mais pas Liliane
Edmond et non et non Liliane elle a elle
a été la vice-présidente de la Société
des Amis elle a je crois qu'elle avait
dit à la maison
elle avait beaucoup de choses non à
Versailles elle a elle a donné des
choses elle a donné des bourses de jeux
et les bourses de jeux avec les
elle a donné elle refait un cadre elle a
donné un très beau cadre pour le
portrait sur une Marie-Antoinette et
surtout dans cette chose la plus
amusante c'est que les filles ont donné
un tableau et une fille a donné un
tableau et l'autre fille a donné la clé
l'énorme clé de la chapelle royale
et on raconte une anecdote que tout le
monde tremblait ils ont fait tourner et
ça marchait
et Nadine à chez elle le secrétaire
c'était amusant parce que tout ça toutes
ces provenances royales c'est très
Rothschild les Rothschild adoraient les
provenances royales et donc
avec le baron de James au début et puis
après les autres branches aussi et donc
Liliane et Nadine était pas rival mais
enfin chacune avait le voilà le bureau
la commode mais ça venait des épouses du
côté Rothschild chanson
on apprend l'histoire
avec Cécile de rothschildagarma
à découvrir au travers des portraits
toutes ces baronnes
c'est amusant et oui non mais on apprend
vraiment plein de choses qu'on ne
soupçonnait pas et puis la la baronne
Nadine qui de Rothschild qui qui met
toujours son petit grain de sel sa
petite touche donc dans chaque portrait
elle est là
je peux quand même dire ce que je pense
lui
et la prochaine fois vous n'avez qu'à
absolument et on tourne à Versailles on
se fait ouvrir la chapelle avec la clé
une photo merci
Eric à très bientôt au revoir à tous
merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]